what are your uh two different types of
doing nothing super interesting like the
distinction and i i had one of those
over the weekend it was a saturday no no
one else in the house i was like i'm
gonna make all this book progress and i
made zero book progress browse youtube
all day and i was listening to the
audiobook last night i was like oh if i
had this terminology of like [ __ ]
nothing i would have called it i would
have just like written the day off but i
didn't and so i felt guilty for the
whole day
so i think that's really really
important and i think that when we're
taught so much how to work and we're not
taught that well how to
take time and
know when we're probably a little bit
burnt out and all of these different
things that actually if we took rest we
would be much better tomorrow the idea
of planned nothing and [ __ ] it nothing
are the fact that actually i believe
wholeheartedly in time management i
believe that time management is stress
management for some people you're going
to be very like taipei and it's going to
be like of course your time managing
like of course at the beginning of your
week you know what your whole week looks
like and all of this other people are
going to be like no i won't know till
the day i do believe though that if you
want to fit a certain amount of things
in you have to be good at time
management and you have to do your 10
000 hours and make yourself good at time
management
you don't have to want to fine i think
that it's really important to also give
a bit of tough love and be like if you
want to do x y and zed you have to play
it's not going to happen without you
planning it so whether that's
starting to go to the gym whether that's
starting a new side hustle or a new
hobby or any of those things if you're
not planning those things in in the same
way as if you don't plan in the gym or
you know if you don't put your doctor's
appointment in your diary it's not gonna
happen
so the idea of like plan nothing and
[ __ ] nothing is when you're looking
at your
week plan and you're doing all your day
plan and you're doing your plan for
yourself i think it's really important
to have enough planned nothing in there
and i don't think we do that because
planning nothing
again seems quite oxymoronic it doesn't
make sense
but knowing your boundaries and getting
to know how you're most productive and
how you're happiest the happiest is
really really important and that all
comes then into your time management so
for me for example i know that from a
monday to thursday so weekdays i'm
probably going to want to
do something two nights
and do nothing two nights
and
that's my limit usually so like this
week i've had something every single
night and i hate it i feel dead i've
started every day feeling like an
absolute zombie i don't have any
thinking time i don't have time to stare
at the ceiling like i don't you know i'm
not able to kind of process things in
the same way and so i get anxious about
things and i get stressed and i don't
feel like
i'm my best self
the way we mitigate that is by
understanding those boundaries and for
me usually
if i look at next week for example and
i've got something in on wednesday and
thursday and someone says are you free
on tuesday i'm not i'm actually not free
on tuesday it might look if you looked
at my diary like i'm free but i'm not
these are my non-negotiables and this is
how i manage myself to be able to be my
best self for my goals whether those are
personal life whether those are work
[ __ ] it nothing
is
understanding that we can plan as much
as we want we can
operate by those rules we can you know i
can know that i'm going out wednesday
and thursday next week for dinner and i
can know that i'm doing tuesday monday
and tuesday in and then whatever the
weekend i've got it all planned and i
can get to wednesday
and i can be like i actually i actually
either don't want to or i can't or i'm
feeling really burnt out or my mental
health isn't there or any of those
things and understanding that we can
plan for absolutely everything and we
can't plan for the fact that we're human
and so [ __ ] it nothing is essentially
being able to be like [ __ ] it
not doing that and i think
important distinction again is like you
get a real dopamine hit when you think
you had to do something and then you
don't have to do something so you have a
plan with some someone and then you you
cancel that plan you get that dopamine
here but then also
you can get into the habit of doing that
because you think you need that and
actually what you needed was to push
yourself out there and go out to dinner
and have a good laugh with someone you
haven't caught up with in a while but it
feels like a chore when you're at the
end of that day and you're like that's
the last thing i want to do so i think
understanding as well the boundaries of
[ __ ] nothing too are really important
but i do think that if we don't have
[ __ ] it nothing
say your saturday night where you were
going to make a huge amount of progress
with the book
and you decide not to what you really
needed in that time was [ __ ] nothing
you needed to be like [ __ ] it i'm doing
absolutely nothing
instead
you probably sat on the sofa being like
i'm meant to be doing something and then
felt
probably you probably didn't get the
benefit of doing nothing and you didn't
get the benefit of doing work and so i
think understanding our human limits and
our boundaries and being able to just
say i'm not going to do that and i know
i'm not going to do that and i'm okay
with not doing that is one of the most
important things you can do for your
productivity and your time management
and your self-care hey friends thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day